Good morning.
My name is Lulu Li.
I'm a fifth-year PhD student
at the Nuclear Science
and Engineering
Department here at MIT.
As [INAUDIBLE] mentioned that
of the various things that
make this place home to me,
I'm particularly honored
to be the co-president
for ACME, which
stands for Academy of
Courageous Minority Engineers.
We're a student group
generously supported under ODGE.
I have the honor here to
be your master of ceremony
today for this event.
Please join me in thanking the
MIT Gospel Choir one more time.
[APPLAUSE]
I would like to introduce
Reverend Rahsaan Hall, who will
lead this morning's invocation.
[APPLAUSE]
Good morning.
Out of respect for all
faiths and religions,
let us come together
collectively
and center ourselves
in a word of prayer.
Great and marvelous creator,
you are our inspiration.
You have been our sustainer
in times of trouble.
In those wilderness experiences,
you have held us in your hand.
We acknowledge your presence
in all that will be done
and said in this place.
You are our inspiration.
In times long forgotten,
you shielded us from harm,
creating pathways where
none existed before.
We humble ourselves before you.
You are our inspiration.
In the face of oppression and
the unjust exercise of power,
you have reminded
us that whoever
closes their ear to the
cry of the poor will
themselves call out
and not be answered.
And we endeavor to listen
with not only open ears,
but open hearts as well.
You are our inspiration.
To be rooted and grounded
in your divine love,
that we might yield our
power to the powerless,
so they may be strong.
Keep us forever in
your path, we pray.
Amen.